see that on Tick Tock collard greens
short ribs white sauce mashed potatoes
maybe most importantly Chef Trish's
famous mac and cheese it was a food
truck turned online sensation now in a
brick and mortar restaurant of their own
when the food is good I start dancing
and I was cutting up in there after
going Mega viral taste buds Grail
kitchen is making moves from this food
truck parked behind this North Las Vegas
Buffalo Wild Wings what is this
is it Christmas again to this space off
Lake Mead and Decatur Latricia Nelson
and her husband Marshawn Nelson are the
chefs behind the counter this is the
face of someone who knows they popped
off and in front of your phone screens
we'll get waves of people like the first
day it was waves of people from Detroit
and then the next day it was waves of
people from San Francisco to Bay Area
their online presence attracting
tourists off the strip I found it on
social media and locals out of the house
I'm from Chicago and living in Vegas you
get a lot of visitors and every single
visitor I've had I've taken there I'm
convinced I just had the best Mac and
Cheese of my life that is actually the
best doing video I've ever done over 4
million have seen this video by Talia
edralin better known to 225 000 tick
talkers as at talls restaurants were
like I don't have the patience to learn
this new skill set can you just take it
over for me she's worked with national
brands from Dutch Bros coffee to Carl's
Jr and manages the social medias for
several Las Vegas restaurants on the low
end her work costs five hundred dollars
for nationally recognized Brands it
could go up to three thousand a person
on the Internet won't remember you in a
week if you only post once a month you
know like you just need to continue to
keep showing up for them show that
you're going to be a staple in their
life and then they'll show you that same
you know energy back and behind hard
work the online marketing what the
owners call a necessity for any modern
business looking to grow social media is
the new billboard it's the new you know
our grandfather might have read the
newspaper we pull out that phone
taste buds oh I got to go there
reporting from Lake Mead in Decatur Ryan
Matthey every time eight news now
that was the happy dance right there
from Ryan the social media manager adds
businesses can do the marketing on their
own but she says it involves Daily Posts
collaborating with other content
creators and hours of dedication the
grand opening for the new restaurant 12
noon tomorrow and it is open to the
public